Про те, що в цьому київському професійному училищі
навчався відомий дизайнер та виробник чоловічого одягу Михайло Воронін,
нам охоче розповідає директорка закладу.
- 1959-й рік випуску.
Юнак у вишиванці - Михайло Воронін.
Як і про світлі часи, коли на спеціальність закрійника та кравця
вишиковувалися черги. Нині ж у цьому закладі профосвіти,
як і скрізь по Україні, недобір студентів.
Аби виконати державне і регіональне замовлення,
уряд продовжив набір до 1 жовтня.
Тут є бюджетні місця ще для 25 студентів.
Чекають переважно на швачок.
- Дуже плачевно, але чомусь наша професія
не так користується попитом.
Дуже погано, але ж це така чудова професія!
Кількість груп зменшується.
Було, черги стояли, щоб подати документи,
а зараз запрошуємо, розказуємо, пропонуємо.
Ані українська молодь, ані їхні батьки
не сприймають профосвіту як щось престижне.
Цей тренд посилюється уже багато років, якщо не десятиліть.
Аби виправити ситуацію, Міністерство освіти
почало популяризувати професійні спеціальності.
Зокрема публікує список топ-професій,
які оплачуються навіть краще, ніж юрист чи економіст,
та є затребуваніші на ринку. Це, приміром,
аграрні, будівельні спеціальності та сфера обслуговування.
Окрім того, рік тому в міністерстві оголосили
масштабну реформу профосвіти.
В її основі - дуальне навчання.
Це коли діти вивчають теорію в закладах профосвіти,
а практичні навички здобувають на підприємствах
в умовах реального виробництва.
Така форма професійної освіти популярна в Європі,
зокрема в Німеччині.
Подібне навчання вирішило б низку проблем:
підприємства отримали б робітників на професії,
де нині нестача робочої сили, а студенти - робочі місця.
Втім, не все так просто.
- Фабрики “Україна” немає, фабрики “Юність” немає,
на базі якої було створено одну з гілок нашого закладу,
фабрики “Воронін” немає.
Тобто великих підприємств немає.
Є маленькі підприємства, які розвиваються,
народжуються.
Є ще юридичні тонкощі, зокрема
тристоронній договір між закладом, учнем і роботодавцем
можна підписати лише з повнолітніми студентами.
В Україні профосвіту здобувають переважно учні, що закінчили 9 класів.
Утім, саму ідею реформи профосвіти
у цьому київському ПТУ підтримують і
вже другий рік втілюють її з групою студентів-кухарів.
Практичні заняття ті отримують у мережі київських ресторанів.
Тонкощі реформи профосвіти прописані в новому законопроекті.
Документ ухвалений урядом, але
ще не проголосований у Верховній Раді.
За даними МОН, до дуальної освіти вже приєдналися 250 ПТУ.
Однак є заклади, де і в умовах старого закону
вдалося вибудувати якісне професійне навчання.
Так, цей технікум у Василькові
вважається одним із найкращих в Україні.
Його директорка Людмила Постоленко за 19 років
аварійне приміщення перетворила і розбудувала
в модерний заклад профільної освіти.
Тут і нове обладнання, і нові підходи в навчанні.
- Ключове - підприємництво.
Тобто для чого ми даємо цю освіту: для того,
щоб дитина стала успішною, відкрила свою власну справу
і почала заробляти кошти.
Сьогоднішні всі всі сучасні виробничі технології -
ну, якщо ми говоримо про швей, - то ми вчимося
сьогодні на прикладі відомих дизайнерів, таких як
Карл Лагерфельд із будинком Chanel,
Крістіан Діор, Dolce & Gabbana, Італія.
Плюс ми вчимо за китайськими і турецькими технологіями.
МОН визнає, що обладнання закладів професійної освіти
зношене на 60%. Подекуди навіть на 100, а це
аж ніяк не сприяє якісній освіті.
У цьому закладі матеріально-технічну базу
вдалося оновити частково за державний кошт,
частково за кошт самого профзакладу.
За нинішнім законом, 50% зароблених студентами
під час виробничої практики грошей ідуть у бюджет ПТУ,
тож навіть на дорогі будівельні матеріали
студенти тут не витрачаються.
- Я не планувала поступати на цю професію, але
з кожним днем вона мені все більше подобається.
Тут можна виразити свою креативність,
можна показати своє вміння.
Ми вивчаємо різні декоративні штукатурки зараз.
Дуальну освіту цей заклад поки не практикує.
Діти проходять практику на виробництві
або працюють у навчально-виробничих центрах
на базі самого технікуму. Тут бачать іншу проблему:
більшість студентів, які здобувають професійні спеціальності,
виїжджають працювати за кордон.
Там і умови праці кращі, і зарплати вищі.
- За кордон думаю. Франція мені подобається, думала у Франції поїхати.
- Хочеться чогось нового спробувати, можна виїхати за кордон.
Можна в Польщу. Заробітна плата більша.
Реформувати професійну освіту в Україні
допомагає і Європейський Союз.
Так, ще рік тому на розробку нових стандартів
викладання та оновлення інфраструктури
ЄС надав 58 мільйонів євро.
Якщо ситуація з навчанням поволі поліпшується,
то наступний крок - за українським бізнесом, який
має запропонувати конкурентні з Європою умови праці.